wow
hey everybody what's going on it's
Friday night
I think last week we did Saturday didn't
we yeah yeah but we decided to do it so
but we are going to go out so we
probably have to like wrap it up before
nine so I can
you know that's plenty of time so I can
get ready yeah I mean I'm kind of
already ready but I just gotta change
clothes and [__] like that you know what
I mean so what connections here what's
the matter losing connections well that
sounds like a personal problem
restart this thing I was telling Tom
that on my way home from work driving
home I was like halfway home and I was
stopped in traffic like at a red light
and I looked over at the on the median
and there was two ducks [__] yeah I
was like Hey free duck porn
that was somebody's lucky day I guess I
was just kind of like okay got murder
Hornets in the damn chat
murderheart has sent me uh all kinds of
[__] from Mexico one of the things he
stands me is [__]
some of that Mexican Viagra
I guess it's from Mexico
getting Jenny [__] up
because I still got all that still got a
lot of that I'm not even done with that
first bottle
how big was the bottle it had 90 pills
in that first bottle yeah
how many of you take just one at a time
one at a time in the last [__] almost
two days
you can run on that for two days yeah
like an erection lasting longer than
four hours please this is a
misconception
they think that you take that pill and
all of a sudden you [__] pop a boat
no I don't know no I made that joke
because that was what the commercial
used to say like that was one of the
they're like that's how you know you
need to go to the doctor like because
that's not right yeah so that's why it's
not how that [__] works well yeah but no
but that but some people did report that
but that's not what it's supposed to do
so that's why they say like go to the
doctor that's what I meant it doesn't
mean that I don't know how it works yeah
I just said that I got a lot of women
that don't know how that works that's
what they say you're gonna take that
just walk around you know that kind of
[__] you know they they'll say that [__]
that kind of [__] to do
yeah
murder Hornet said I take two yeah
damn dude for double the double the
erection
it's just serious man
that's funny yeah
the [__] difference between just like
a regular [__] Woody and a [__]
and a
and a Viagra it's like a difference
between natural titties and [__]
implants it's like it's like it's it's
that there's that amount of difference
in there [__] all those [__] porn
dudes so I can run that [__]
well yeah I guess you'd have to because
yeah there's no mind in it you don't
have to I can
you have to worry about [__] keeping
keeping your [__] [__] rocked up
if you're aroused that shit's gonna be
rocked out well like that's their job
you know so
they have to do all those scenes that I
don't know but you know they probably
have to do a lot per day I'd imagine my
gay porn buddy
who's also sells me [__]
is a straight all kind of drug dealers
yeah he's another drug he's a drug
yeah he's a he's a straight dude that
does [__] gay muscle porn
got a girlfriend and everything he
claims to be straight I mean he tells me
all kinds of [__] he tried to get me to
work with them and I'm like dude no I do
know I mean he goes it's not like we
have to kiss or anything
[__] are you talking about man but
anyway
Viagra isn't enough for him he [__]
injects some [__] in there he told me
what it was I forgot what it was
says you can inject that [__] into your
dick
and [__] you don't have Choice you're
gonna be rocked up [__]
six hours
he says this shit's painful
yeah you can have fun with it after six
hours yeah he said yeah he says it'll
[__] you up though you can't do it real
um
you can't do it real often or you'll be
dependent on that
you know what I mean yeah you'll have to
you do you have done that can build up a
dependency on it
is that like um chemical or
psychological or um
I think it might be like it usually is
because I've noticed that Viagra has
some psychological dependency involved
in it you feel a lot better more
confident if you're on that [__] yeah
you know I mean if you're not on it
you're gonna be like you know what
[__] the quality of this [__]
erection is not going to be like it was
before that's not going to be that good
so then you start getting under this
dick thing man that's a quality like
yeah this dick and you're like man then
you start you think about your dick too
much you just not let [__] happen you
know
just not going to yeah so I think
[__] Viagra might be
a dangerous way to go but you just do it
anyway
you know you do it anyway
I thought so many drugs anyway no one
lives forever you know you don't live
forever yeah I got 20 or 30 years left
anyway don't matter what's up Dave hey
you two Jenny looking great Tom looking
buff thank you very much thank you I'm
assuming you're going to mannequins
we're going to go to mannequins a little
bit as well later on after the show and
after I change clothes and do various
other things yeah because I just got
home from work a little while ago had
some tacos those are good tacos by the
way oh you're welcome
making the tacos what'd you do today
what did you do what did you do I rode
the uh the lightning bolt and uh took it
all the way down the freeway and went to
the um
Starbucks near old house and Brit was
working there
and uh
trying to find you a new girlfriend and
then yeah I got one I got one he's got
one in mine I got one in mine but she
might be pretty I don't know
not barely your type but
kind of like a
imagine if a black metal chick and a and
a hippie chick had a baby like a lesbian
baby
yeah she's pretty but she she's she's
she's very friendly I showed her I
showed her to you and everything told
her about the club man he's like trying
to like he's like a dangerous cool about
it you know
there's nothing like that there's
nothing like that I was just letting her
know I can't I can't trust you because I
don't know what the [__] I don't know
what the [__] kind of [__] you're saying
though
[Laughter]
Dave said it should be room to dance
tonight well what is is there anything
particular going on tonight is it like a
theme or is it it's not baby bats and
it's not like what's going on because I
always like I never keep track you know
what I mean even though a lot of times I
do the posters and stuff but it's like I
can't remember because I do so much
stuff
murder Hornet says no more trend for Tom
dude
that's cool
oh yeah she's super cute
she's got the white hair with the braids
and all that and the chokers she looks
slightly like don't and yeah yeah don't
tell her I said this she looks slightly
like a goth Britney Spears yeah a little
bit in that picture yeah I don't know
what she looks like in real life like
that
Dave says nothing just v13 okay so maybe
it'll be it won't be like super packed
because I don't think there's anything
like going on tonight is there it's not
a holiday it's not
it's nothing
now you did not go down to downtown
Sanford last night you were thinking
about it no I think we just stayed home
and no I went Tuesday yeah two days
Tuesday was good man bike night I liked
it oh yeah you should start making you
make that a regular thing I guess yeah
last night we started watching uh
top gun Maverick yeah it didn't finish
it because it's all right well because
it's long and it's like by the time we
started it I was like you know I'm
probably gonna fall asleep before this
is over Ray because I don't think we
started it until like 8 or 8 30 and it's
like two and a half hours long it
probably we got like halfway through it
probably would have been we haven't seen
the rest of it but it probably would
have been
um
better in the theater because you
probably would have got wrapped up more
caught up in with the soundtrack in the
visuals and more in the uh they're
really leaning into Nostalgia trying to
reboot the Nostalgia it was okay it's so
far it's good
yeah I'm gonna say like I'm only halfway
through but it's like I I mean and this
is coming from somebody that didn't like
the first one
um it's all right yeah it's all right I
don't I don't love it but the thing
about it is that the first one it it
really is a continuation of the first
one so everyone is like a cocky [__]
that I just want to punch in the mouth
uh just like the first one so so I was
like well they've got that going for it
but you know
Trey says [__] I forgot it was Friday
what's up everyone yeah I think like
well because sometimes we don't mean to
be confusing but sometimes
um we change it to Saturdays like last
week we decided to change it to
Saturdays and we went out on Friday and
we're going out this Friday too but we
decided we were just gonna do it before
we went out because I'm not I'm tired
but I'm not that tired you know what I
mean I mean I fell asleep
what time do we turn the movie off 10 9
30 no probably like 9 30. he's coming up
on tan and then like then I was like
yeah just go to work so yeah I gotta I
gotta go sleep so I I only woke up like
one time in the night like to go to the
bathroom and I think it was like two or
two thirty and then like I woke up like
right before five so
Trey says now it was all me but one of
those weeks where I keep forgetting what
day it was yeah
Louie said Jenny have you guys watched
the last of us we haven't yet but
everybody like tells everybody's I'll
get around to it I swear because I
really do need to watch it evidently it
finally ending The Walking Dead
the last yeah yeah yeah trying to get
rid of that I don't even know what the
hell is going on with that anymore like
I stopped watching a couple of Seasons
again it just after they killed Glenn it
kind of like went downhill the the
writing got bad
oh and then John Wick chapter four is
out because Danny rolling said yeah John
Wick chapter four is just like the rest
of the wick series unbelievable fight
scenes that looks choreographed and not
natural pretty much the bad guys just
stand there wait to be beat Yeah well
yeah that's what you pay to see yeah two
hours and 43 minutes holy [__] damn holy
[__]
that's a long movie
I mean I could I could watch a John Wick
movie I really like the John Wick movies
actually
but they're better to see in the theater
too
uh they're having spin-offs of Walking
Dead yeah I thought they already had
like a bunch of spin-offs weren't they
doing I thought they were doing like a
Daryl and Carol one or something
I don't know I thought that I heard that
a long time ago but about the um top
What Fear The Walking Dead sucked
it was okay at the beginning but then it
just kind of got Fallen apart and
falling apart I didn't really I didn't
really like any of the characters yeah
you know what I mean well they had some
what's his name strand no remember the
black guy with the [__] yacht
I thought that was gonna be like a real
[__] cool character in terms of I
forgot what his I think his name was
strand I think something like that
um I was like this dude must be some
kind of double 07 secret agent or
something no he's just some gay dude
trying to get back to his boyfriend it
was just like what the [__] that's about
it is that they kind of set up it's
almost kind of like they set up all this
stuff and then like some more writers
came in and we're just kind of like well
I don't really feel like I want to yeah
we're not gonna do that yeah I think
that's what happened that's all this
dude was so what about all that [__]
secret [__] what about all that [__]
high speed
it seemed like this dude was like James
Bond and it turns out yeah it seemed
like they were setting him up yeah to be
like a secret agent yeah which like I
said he could still be a gay dude
looking for his boyfriend but it's like
I thought he was like a secret yeah like
I thought that's what his job was I mean
he yeah I thought he was a secret agent
I mean because that's what I thought
that they were setting up and that's
what it should have been then they
didn't really do that that's what
exactly what it should have been because
think about it you got the zombie
apocalypse right you got a zombie
apocalypse you saw what some redneck
bikers would do
there was two good characters out of
that one the [__] one of them got
killed uh you saw what some some [__]
redneck cops what they would do and then
you saw what some chicks would do right
regular southern women
what would James Bond do
in the zombie now I kind of feel like
that has not been explored yeah maybe
that should be the next James Bond movie
well
that had the perfect they had the
perfect character
that black dude who was like a secret
agent
and then they had the uh the Sandinista
guy
or the Contra the ex-contra guy who was
tortured yeah yeah yeah Salazar and then
that didn't seem to go anywhere like you
know yeah that's what I mean it seemed
like they had a lot of cool ideas but
they didn't really like know what to do
with them like they were really good at
set but I kind of feel like this is a
problem with like a lot of a
particularly horror but I don't know but
I just maybe know more about that
because I read a lot more of it but some
people have like really great ideas like
novels movies everything like that and
like the build up the build up it's like
really good I'm like holy [__] I'm like
so intrigued and then like the ending
it's like there's just always like well
I think what was it I kind of feel like
that happens I think what really
happened with The Walking Dead is that
the first season or the first half of
the season was like you said was written
by one writers some you know one group
of writers and then then it was written
by another group of writers that
reversed everything the first ones did
and I think what it was is that
originally they were it was going to be
a story about
some pretty special people who had
survived the apocalypse like a secret
agent you know what I mean an ex-contra
[__] torturer all right an
interrogator basically
dudes it had came pre-packaged with
certain skills in their background of
how they survived this
and then they went you know that were
aliens and then another group came and
says that will alienate the audience
what if we just make these all regular
people like the audience they'll
identify with them that's not how
storytelling goes yeah but the thing
about it was that the original Walking
Dead was just regular ass people and
that was good but it's like it if you're
gonna do a spin-off like do something
different a little bit like you said I
like the idea of doing like people that
aren't aren't just like regular people
that are just kind of like that are to
have specialized skills yeah even see
how they deal with it you could argue
that in the original Walking Dead those
weren't regular people though especially
the first three or four seasons you had
a cop
you had regular people but the regular
people were getting killed
well yeah but I mean you had regular
people well I mean you had Carol who was
just like a you know like a like an
abused spouse yeah you had um Glenn who
was a pizza delivery guy yeah so both of
those characters changed a lot right
right right but no I'm just saying like
just from the start like it was
generally just a bunch of like regular
people they they went down off the deep
end and got really [__] tough you
know from [__] just they got battle
hardened yeah but their leaders were
already people that were already tough
you had some cops okay they were they
could they provided some leadership
even though they turned on one another
over a woman that was a [__] great
story between what was his name
[__]
what were the two cops and names uh
remember Rick and Rick Rick and um
he ended up being
he ended up being cast as The Punisher
and The Punisher series sucked
um
can I just say uh thank you to Jeffy art
who sent us a super chat a while back
what'd you say uh making Disco Fries
while contemplating my life choices LOL
sort of just kidding also enjoying a
bottle of red wine a whole bottle all
right yeah uh have a cocktail on me
thank you very much that's very very
nice of you
Danny Rowling said The Walking Dead
never showed how the survivors were
surviving without toilet paper what they
were using instead
believes and [__] well the thing about
it was that I mean for a while you could
use actual toilet paper because there
would just be toilet paper laying around
at the stores itself yeah it'd be a lot
of it Shane that was it Shane that's
right I was like I knew it started with
an S I was like Sean if that's not right
I thought Shane was one of the best
characters
out of all the Walking Dead I thought he
was pretty
accurate to what did what some dudes
would do you know
um
and then uh the two Dixon Brothers
yeah
guys like that would would survive the
zombie apocalypse just [__]
crazy [__]
real hardcore
redneck super poor
biker type dudes you know criminals
they'd make it you know because they're
already kind of like bombs living in
houses really uh yeah they're like um
[Laughter]
we already don't have toilet paper yeah
um do you guys think that Negan
overstayed his welcome in the series
probably so um I don't even know what
ended up happening with him because like
we kind of I like that actor I like um
Jeffrey D Morgan a lot like I've liked
him in other things and I liked that
character at first but it kind of got
old you know what I mean yeah like his
sort of like over the top and it kept
building it up like something's gonna
happen it never would happen
well like I said that's kind of another
thing and I see that in a lot of horror
media these are like novels movies
everything like I said it's easy to come
up with an idea and to like get all
wrapped up in the story and like the
build up and everything like that but
then it's got to go someplace that you
know that's that makes the journey like
worth it and a lot of people can't
really seem to do that you know which
you know even Stephen King like some of
his endings are like yeah
they had some really good characters to
uh crazy ass black dude here's not here
he was in the very first [__]
he was in the very first Morgan Morgan
he was in the very first episode and you
don't see him anymore and he's
got a whole town as a big [__] Ambush
site
and Rick
walks into his Ambush site and he goes I
remember you he was wearing a dead man's
face he said a lot of crazy [__] when he
was crazy
that played that kind of made me think
that
he said he saw him he saw somebody
wearing a dead man's face I was thinking
man was somebody wearing zombie body
parts to blend in with zombies I think
they were going to go that way well
wasn't that in the comic wasn't that The
Whispers or something I think they
eventually did get to that but it took
like a really long time to get it took
him a long time to get to these shits
he's drawn he was dropping hints and
stuff but he could that actor was
[__] great he's a British guy yeah
yeah and he could play a crazy dude yeah
I love that dude he can't yes Lenny
James is his name yeah and that Morgan
character was cool I liked him much
better when he was crazy they never
should have brought him back to sanity
he was just better crazy
that they should have maybe brought him
back a little bit to sanity but I think
they should have left him crazy
but you know the thing about it is that
when you have
in some ways I kind of feel like writing
a book or writing a movie is probably
easier than writing a series because
when you're writing a series you have no
[__] idea like how long that's gonna
go on look how long the Walking Dead has
been on and it's like after a while
they're like look you know we've done
everything like what the [__] else is
there to do it's like well this
character went nuts so let's make them
normal again then they'll go nuts again
it's like there's really only so many
things you can do I guess that first
three or four seasons I thought were
just great horror survival
series you could actually learn from it
there was some some of some of the stuff
situations and some of the decisions
that they made
were actually the kind of stuff you'd
have to do in a in a military type
environment
when it was that dire that you know
because their situation was bad
um but then later on when it started
getting to these
dudes with the with the Tigers and the
the yeah
and then all and then these people that
were like crows or ants or something oh
the ones in the in the junkyard yeah and
then that's like a little too weird I
don't honestly I don't know like I've
never been through a zombie apocalypse
obviously but it's like I just I feel
like that probably wouldn't happen yeah
and then
they were doing things like hiding
behind corrugated tin to stop [__]
AK-47 rounds and [__] no no you see that
in movies all the time what the [__] are
these people you know you're giving
people a very
incorrect [__]
impression of [__] assault rifles you
know
even cars won't stop assault rifle
rounds the engine block will but no man
you could line up [__] 10 cars and
shoot through all the doors and that
[__] round would probably go through
six seven of them I mean probably better
marginally better to be behind a car
than just like out in the open but not
by much probably mostly just for
concealment yeah so they can't see you
well just look at the look at the uh
that one California shooting with the
guys were holding off all the cops what
was that uh what was the name of that
shooting
where the uh the guys that went to rob
the bank and they held off the entire
[__] lap yeah we did a show about
that yeah we watched the movie about it
yeah Emil and the other guy are email
and the other guy
and they were wearing all that body
armor
and uh you can see email or Emil or emel
I've heard it I've heard it I'm assuming
it's a meal a meal right I don't
he's trying to hide behind a car and
they just shot underneath it and shot
his legs Out Underneath Him
you know they don't and he was trying to
hide behind the engine block
and he's shooting back at him going
right through and you can see him
shooting at the cops and he's shooting
through the
through the uh the driver's window and
the rounds are going straight through
the window and out the back and those
guys are ducking trying to get from
underneath him cars won't stop bullets
got out of a rifle pistol bullet
you know a little bit he might can
deflect some but even even a pistol nine
millimeter pistol will go through two
car doors easily
Danny Rowling said Tom savini was trying
really hard to be cast as the governor
but lost out to an English actor yeah
that's right uh yeah what was that
actor's name David Morrissey or
something like that that was good mainly
because he looked exactly like the comic
book version of the governor which would
have been epic I liked that character
but it's like that would have been that
have been kick ass if Tom savini had
been in there
I mean you think because yeah it was a
good character like but you know how
much cooler would it have been if it was
Tom savini
because him and Greg Niger are friends
right because Greg nicatero was Tom
savini's like understudy for a long time
Tom savini isn't a great actor though
yeah but I mean that's okay he's cool
he's Tom [__] Savannah yeah the guy
that did the guy
that did uh that did the governor was a
lot better actor yeah I've seen him in
some other things too like David
Morrissey I think his name is I think
his first name is David right
yeah
yeah that was like that was I don't even
remember what season that was because we
used to watch it live like we used to
actually that was the only thing that we
watched on cable TV like we would always
watch it whenever it was on Sunday night
or whenever it was like we would always
it was like appointment TV he'd always
like sit down and watch it but then like
after a while I would just like stopped
watching it and then I started watching
I don't even know what season they're on
now I started watching like one season
and then I was just kind of like lost
interest like halfway through yeah Louie
called it again it's the [__] North
Hollywood shootout yeah we did a show
about that didn't we yeah we did a show
we did mm-hmm
yeah Daniel let's talk about the Tiger
yeah it just got to a point like look
you know in a comic book because I know
that was from the comic
in a comic book you can get away with
like absurd [__] like that this is just
going back to like the kind of [__] that
I always say and I'd usually say this
when I'm talking about Stephen King's
stuff but it's like you know why they
change certain things in a book
or a comic you can get away with a lot
more absurdity than you can get away
with in a movie like especially if the
movie is supposed to be in any way
realistic and I kind of feel like
walking dead is supposed to be realistic
yeah they're walking corpses but other
than that it's pretty gritty and like
grounded in reality so it's like
I just don't see I don't think that in
real life if there was a zombie
apocalypse I just don't think that you
would see these themed uh communities of
people like this is you know this is
like we're gonna pretend it's like
medieval times it's like you know we're
gonna all live in the junkyard and all
like walking like I just don't think
that would happen no I just don't think
that would happen no I'll tell you what
though um what was better than the than
the later walking dead were the video
games
you didn't have much time to make
decisions and yeah but it was good the
story the writing in it was was with the
writing in them was good that one that
you had was like was so good that it was
like man you got like all choked up at
the end because you got like really into
the characters you know yeah it was when
we were playing the little girl yeah
yeah yeah that was it see that was a
really good game yeah that was a really
good game so you know yeah Louis said
same thing happened to me with Walking
Dead I just lost interest yeah yeah it
just got you know I really liked all the
characters but then it seemed like then
um you know some of the characters I
really liked like Glenn got killed and
then everybody and then they started
adding more characters and more
communities and it's like so the
characters that I liked didn't get much
time anymore you know because they were
trying to give everybody equal time and
it was just getting too like bloated and
I was just kind of like I couldn't keep
track of everything
Zach says fact I'm late again oh he's
typing in all caps are you drunk already
Zach it's okay you can be honest
[Laughter]
Danny Rowling said also as many seasons
there are of The Walking Dead there's no
way there would be zombies they'd all be
decayed and [__] after the fourth season
see I was thinking that too I was just
like at what point are they gonna be
like too rotted to like [__] walk
around I don't think they rot
see what okay they're gonna like have
some science to like come up with that
because like you know they're they're
clearly dead because they're all Grody
and [__] decayed looking yeah so it's
like yeah okay their Decay is slowed or
whatever if you want to go that I gotta
have some kind of metabolism going on in
there there yeah do they [__] what you
know what is do they eat well they eat
so they gotta [__] it out they produce
energy otherwise they explode
they eat and they walk around they
produce energy
uh so there's a metabolism
I said they might as well be [__]
alive so they're kind of like alive
yeah they're alive-ish yeah
that's what they are but yeah like I
said you would think after a while since
they were all rotted and stuff and then
like sometimes they'd still be walking
around like after somebody cut their
arms off or some [__] like that and it's
like you think after a while like they
just wouldn't like their legs would rot
or somebody would cut one of their legs
off and they would just kind of lay
there and go well if they were in the
water they'd blow it up remember think
it's soft you could pull them apart
yeah you know that's right oh that was a
great [__] when they pulled that one
out of the well yeah that was amazing
they got waterlogged and it was like
yeah so I bet they had a [__] blast
like making that so they also must have
had some kind of a uh uh
like a defense mechanism against
bacteria and things because they like I
said they would have rotten yeah you
know but they didn't they did Decay a
little bit it looked like but not not
much yeah you think like after a while
it'd just be like [__] skeletons
coming after you like a ray Harry out of
the Moon yeah
[Laughter]
that'll be the next season they had some
kind of an immune system
uh kalon hicken said uh didn't a zombie
speak
did the zombies talk on walking dead
because I stopped watching it I don't
think I know they talked one of them
talked in like the in the Romero movies
yeah like he just said one word or
something yeah but I've never heard any
of them talk and uh
I think that would kind of like ruin it
I mean at least in the universe that
they'd said I'm not averse to like
zombies talking because but it all has
to do with like what kind of zombies
you're setting up you know what I mean
here's another thing that they could
have done with The Walking Dead is they
could have there could have been run
into a situation into a situation where
they found a person who was like half a
zombie
where they had it
but they only turned halfway
how would that manifest they could still
talk yeah and they could kind of control
things but they could kind of control
themselves but then they'd lose control
maybe try to eat you
but they were also dead
that would be kind of cool so it'd be
more like a vampire yeah you know more
like a vampire yeah you could go that
route where a person turned but they
were were able to keep their mind and
they could control their hunger a little
bit
intermittently that'd be interesting
yeah I wonder if it I didn't read the
comics so I don't really know if any of
that stuff it was a disease of some sort
they said it was remember they said it
was a virus yeah because they said that
like even that was like the end of the
first season right or the end of the
second season where they said that it
was yeah it's basically like they tried
to give like a [__] scientific
explanation for it where it's like oh
it's this thing that re-energizes your
brain so if it's a disease that means
there would be a person that could catch
it but that would be kind of immune
right or have a resistance
yeah [__] man they even did that in um
in I am legend or you know like Omega
Man which is kind of which were more
like vampires but still
yeah like you could get it but then like
you could be cured of it yeah
um let's see Dave said I stopped
watching only because I got too behind
after their last and final season but
now they're gonna have uh the group that
did live have their own shows three or
four different shows uh and he said The
Whispers spoke okay yeah they weren't
zombies though well wait a minute were
they I don't think that's I don't think
I don't know I don't remember I think
there were people dressed up as zombies
Hugo again like asked if we've seen the
last of us we gotta watch we gotta watch
it because like literally 40 million
people they're saying it's the opposite
that it has a lot better characters yeah
and you love post-apocalyptic [__] so
you'd probably be really into it
um didn't the Vampire Zombies in the
Omega Man speak yes they did they were
essentially just kind of like
they weren't vampires well in the novel
they were yeah but not not in the Omega
Man in the novel they were
and the Omega Man they were just uh
mutants yeah they were psychopathic
mutants that kind of came down with um
albinoism they couldn't they couldn't
they were blind in the daylight
they lost all their pigment
pigmentations
and uh they became Psychopaths
and uh they were under the control of a
dude named Matthias who was an old
television reporter and he went all
[__]
an Arco [__] Marxist or whatever he's
trying to [__] destroy all everything
that had come before you know destroy
the wheel uh all of Technology because
that was what response was responsible
man that's throwing the baby out with
you yeah bath water so they kind of
became the Inquisition they're wearing
[__] robes and
you know and [__] trying to hunt down
and burn all the libraries and
but it was only showing what happened
what was happening in L.A
it didn't show what was happening
anywhere else
so
I don't know if the mutants maybe
behaved differently in other places
which I would think maybe they would
yeah I suppose so it was just that one
guy right who was controlling him he
basically formed a cult
it took over City Hall and everything
yeah everybody's saying The Last of Us
is really really good I keep seeing it
like pop up on the thing and I'm just
like man I really gotta get into that
but you know we just we usually just end
up watching a movie or
you know or I usually just end up
watching
like some [__] like cooking show or
something like that because it's like I
was like do I really want to make that
commitment because I don't know like how
long it'll take for me for me to watch
the whole thing
we saw uh I Am Legend again with uh Will
Smith
and the movie was a lot better than I
remembered it it's still not good though
it's still not that good I don't like it
I had remembered it incorrectly I
thought that he was
in quarantined New York
and that uh he was in there trying to
stop the
stop the infection and that the outside
world was intact and they were talking
to him for some reason I thought that
you must be thinking of a different
movie yeah but no he was the last guy
yeah yeah I mean that's kind of the
whole premise of the okay I thought they
[__] up they didn't what they [__]
up were the were the mutants themselves
they were just CGI
generic mutants they didn't talk
and the the
book and the story that was based on
it it is you know it's super important
that that the mutants talk that the
vampires talk basically they're vampires
because they're the new Humanity yeah
you know
[__] and the Omega Man
yeah and they just thought of him as a
monster
which they would yeah because that's how
they perceive things yeah like I said
that was the whole point of the novel
and I kind of feel like none of the
movie The Vincent Price one the last man
on Earth is the most it's not yeah it's
super accurate but it's the most
accurate of the three adaptations that
have been made
um I put it right there with a Mega Man
underneath the Mega Man in terms of just
I mean I'll watch anything with Vincent
Price in it that's for sure I like I
like the chest in man Charlton Heston
[__] Omega Man I would love to remake
that move that movie
I just want somebody to make an
adaptation of I Am Legend that's like
the book nobody's really done that
I've never read the book so I don't know
yeah Louis said I Am Legend is one of
those books that nobody has been able to
translate into a great movie yeah really
not and the weird thing about
some book
really know like what the problem is
ever because everybody wants to [__]
with it everybody wants to change it and
I don't know like I said I don't really
know if people that are writing the
script for it like get what the point of
the book is Louie out out of the three
movies which one do you like the best
and drop it in the comments section
I think it's Omega Man I mean a Mega Man
is a is a great movie I really like a
Mega Man but it's not that much like the
book like I said I like the Vincent
Price one probably slightly more because
Vince and Bryce and also it's a lot more
like the book and I dig that so just
something about it the Will Smith went
on a like at all
I liked it a lot better than it wasn't
as terrible as I remembered I'll give it
that but it's still not good and like I
said a lot of it it doesn't have
anything to do with Will Smith he's you
know all charismatic and all that [__]
but it's like
um like you said I didn't really like
it's just too cgie yeah that's they were
doing that kind of [__] and they changed
the ending which I thought was stupid as
hell I think you said Omega Man there
didn't it yeah yeah
yeah Omega Man I mean I probably like
Omega Man and last man on Earth probably
about the same like they're very
different movies even though they're
ostensibly based on the same thing but I
don't know the tone of them is very
different I can pop Omega Man in
any time of the day or night and watch
that [__] and get and get I probably
could too yeah and enjoy it it's a
comforting movie yeah there's something
about it
the way they show LA and mtla and him
[__]
doing his [__] security sweeps with
the with the equipment that he had he
had that [__] convertible
Mustang and that [__] Smith and
Wesson MK 760 nine millimeter seven
machine gun with a [__] flashlight
underneath it
it's just cool [__] you know these guys
tape recorder he's trying to figure out
where they live where the nest is you
know it's like a and then he's got his
[__] hockey Paradise
so what's his name called it
he's got that old Brownstone
where he used to live [__] he's got
it fortified like a [__] Fortress
spotlights and everything
I love that he like actually takes the
time to like dress up put on his velvet
frock coat yeah and like and have his
brandy or whatever and he's playing
chess with the with the bust yeah that's
like that's very funny to me it's Friday
I dress up on Friday yeah yeah that's
probably some [__] I would do too yeah
well that's what I mean it's like if you
were the only person left on Earth you
thought you were I mean it would become
you'd go crazy if you didn't have some
kind of structure or you didn't have
some kind of purpose you know what I
mean so you would probably have to do
what he was doing I mean it seems funny
but it's not really that funny I mean
you're just kind of trying to
you know you're trying to like eek some
happiness out of
out of your life so you're like I'm just
gonna do whatever [__] I want for this
kind of routine right that's what I mean
I think that would like really help a
lot
you keep so you can keep track of the
passage of time and stuff right and uh
you could do like holidays you put up a
Christmas tree and all I would probably
do that [__] I think most people
probably had some badass guns too you
had a [__] Browning 50. upon his roof
bunch of sandbags
he had a bar with a with uh active IR
light on the front of it so you have
night vision
old-fashioned IR night vision
he had an MP40 MK 760.
I'm trying to think what else he had in
there
just other [__] you know just other [__]
other [__] that black chick had a
[__] cool pistol she had a [__] um
a chrome
Colt O3 pocket Hammer listen [__] 32
shoes get down there yeah be cool you
remember that [__] get on a motorcycle
you better ride you know
she's pretty cool she's on that black
panther ship she was badass yeah big old
fro
look cool man I like those little
haircuts those little [__] afro
hairdos that girls would wear in the 70s
just a big round ball
yeah the guys wear those too yeah but uh
yeah they look good because they're just
like [__] it just a big old ball yeah
that's all right it looks good
it does actually I mean it depends on
the person just like everything else she
was thin so it looked really good on her
well yeah it came up out of the jawline
just a big old round ball
yeah
uh Danny rolling said Omega Man is so
good that I own the VHS DVD and a
Blu-ray
Danny rolling okay yeah also the last
man on Earth was inspiration for the
Romero ghoul looks but more scarier
looking than another Living Dead zombies
in my opinion yeah yeah that's uh that's
where um
Romero got the idea because yeah if you
didn't know last man on Earth came out
in 19
63. I'm trying to three when did the
novel come out
1959 I want to say or 1960 I can't
actually remember Danny I was gonna make
a damn doll a Neville
because you know they sell
these like generic blank dolls they're
in a certainly they're like a 12 inch
action figure like the size of a GI Joe
yeah I think they're usually 12 inches
they're GI Joe size and they're kind of
generic
and you can buy
dudes are selling [__] um
faces they're like 3D printed faces
they're kind of bootleg but you can get
Charles heston's head
and you put that on it
you can get Charleston yeah yeah yeah
you're hurting and I was gonna get the
[__] I was gonna get his get that
Blue flight suit
and a [__] officer's cap
and uh get the MK 760 and I'll be able
to make a Neville remember at the very
end where he's in his [__] flight
suit and he's got his [__] officer's
cap on yeah they sell Air they sell
everything to make that that's that's
pretty cool it would have been about a
hundred and something bucks to get it
done but I would have had a [__] full
Neville with [__] Charlton heston's
face and everything but you got a paid
the face
if I got paid for it I could get to pay
for it yeah yeah go to bed bad ass
and uh you could you can buy all a check
to see you know do they have that offset
and they actually somebody actually sold
a package an Omega Man Neville package
it didn't come with the head but it came
with all the clothes and the gun and
everything and the gun had the
flashlight on it
it was it was 3D printed see isn't that
awesome yeah you can make any character
pretty much is that awesome though did
you ever see you make a doll a bit like
nerds around the world now and you can
get like anything you want yeah
they scan the [__] faces and they
make a 3D [__] printing of that head
and evidently a lot of that shit's
copyrighted and you don't have they
don't they can't use images so it's kind
of like yeah you gotta come up with like
work around there's work arounds but
that's [__] definitely Charlton
Heston yeah yeah
because normally I kind of feel like I
guess it depends on their contracts but
I guess you know you have to pay for use
of their image
uh but
I don't know it kind of depends on the
characters because sometimes you can
like you know make dolls or make little
action figures with that with your
outfit on and that's not copyrighted I
don't think
Louie said I know you guys know this but
in the Omega man that was all downtown
LA no CGI yeah no yeah they did I was
like everything empty they did I mean
they did a good job yeah like if you're
gonna be real nitpicky it's like every
now and then you can see like a cargo
but it's like honestly I never really
noticed that until somebody pointed it
out yeah but yeah it looks amazing and
it's like that's almost kind of that's
kind of like
um because I feel like they did that in
[__] uh 28 Days Later too but with
London like they made that look totally
empty too and that was [__] amazing
see I first saw that
it's probably I probably saw it around
the same time uh Louis Hernandez saw it
when I was a little kid at La
and it was probably it was uh maybe
around 76.
maybe yeah 76 77 around that those two
years and they played that [__] on
television on Channel 13.
K httv I think a KT TV I think it was
what the name of that channel was
and they played that for like the uh
monster matinee
and I was about eight maybe seven or
eight and watched that [__] and I wasn't
sure what I was [__] seeing but it
was scaring the [__] out of me this dude
was running around and he was Finding
dead people in the bed
that had been dead for a long time you
know when devil was pulling and pulled
the sheets back and be a dead person
like that he's looking for [__] you know
like he's by himself and he's running by
himself there is no phone ringing damn
it there is no phone
and I go yeah there's a phone there's a
phone right over there
yeah that's right there wouldn't be a
phone would there you know what I mean
it just yeah they don't use the phone
there's no he's by himself yeah no one's
calling you yeah
and uh it made an impression on me
and then
the mutants in the robes that [__]
scared me
and I was watching this [__] during the
daytime they're scaring me
and what really [__] me up is uh
when they killed the little kid
they went that far yeah because you
don't usually normally they didn't kill
it nowadays you don't really see it they
do it more nowadays I kind of feel like
but um every time like back in the 80s
when you saw a movie that killed a kid
it was usually like Italian because they
didn't give a [__] but um they killed
Richie yeah
that's [__] up yeah he was he was uh
he was what was the woman's name
the black chicks little little it was
the black chick's little brother yeah
and he went back to go try to reason
with the mutants hey you know he's got
the Cure we can all go back the way we
were and we can all go back to the way
we were like no [__] that [__] yeah okay
the next thing you know they got his ass
crucified and [__] Neville finds him
because they're trying to rescue him and
when I saw that kid [__] and he's
like friendly as [__] you know what I
mean you're another little kid you're
vibing with him oh yeah yeah okay maybe
it'll work out no it didn't work out
well that's what that was what was like
so horrifying because he was like a nice
kid he just thought he could hey I had
it and I we got rid of it Neville he
cured me we can all go back to the way
we were yeah he thought well he was just
a kid so he thought well you know not
when they see that like it can be cured
now that like everything will be all
right but so I was I was [__] up when
I saw that because I was probably just
only a little bit younger than that kid
how old do you think he was he was
probably about 10 wasn't he no he was
older than older than that I kind of I
thought he was more like 13 or 14. but I
don't know he seemed like a little like
a teenager okay I thought he was a
little bit younger than that maybe but
it's I mean it's been a while since I've
seen it but he's not been 13 or 14. I
was thinking like okay 14. that was
probably about seven but I'm not good at
guessing people but you know I just saw
him as a kid and you know what I mean so
I'm identifying with that character like
yeah yeah maybe he's right you know and
but now man when I saw it when I saw it
he was when I saw him dead like that and
he was [__] up there crucified they
didn't quite show you closely what they
did but I think he was nailed up to to
nailed yeah it was like they didn't even
kill him that's like they [__] did
that yeah and he died later
when Neville saw him and I was like man
they killed that kid and then all of a
sudden everything ramped up because when
you're a little kid normally it when
you're watching these monster movies
little kids you'll see kids in the in
the monster movies but they they live
yeah they'll be safe yeah but they'll
really [__] you up sometimes when the
kid dies you're like oh [__] this one's
serious man this movie's [__] serious
they're killing little kids in it now
yeah yeah honestly I know this is a
[__] up thing to say but as a horror
fan I always kind of like respect when
somebody's willing to go the distance
yeah and kill a little kid in a movie
well I told you I don't like it when
they kill kitties and puppies because I
kind of feel like that's a cheap shot
but they had to kill Richie in that
movie because not enough people were
being killed and and the the and the the
family is what they were called the uh
the the
mutants they had to be
portrayed as real threats
yeah if he's that's how crazy they were
right and if they didn't happen you
wouldn't respect them right you wouldn't
be afraid of them yeah they were funny
well like I said that's kind of like you
know story wise yeah you have to make
them scary and in order to make them
scary they have to do like some [__]
up yeah
and killing a kid like that especially a
really nice one that was actually trying
to help them yeah he's really [__] up
so uh the book came out in 1954 says
Louis he checked for me thank you
I you know why I thought it was 1959 I
don't know if this is gonna sound random
but I thought it was 1959 because that's
when Shirley Jackson's The Haunting of
Hill House came out so for some reason I
thought they came out the same year but
I guess not so yeah 1954 that's old and
um yeah Richard Matheson was way ahead
of his time yeah I agree actually he's
one of my favorite writers I mean the
dude
he wrote like so much good [__] and it's
like he wrote all the best Twilight Zone
episodes
um he just wrote some great [__]
novels that they made into great [__]
movies it's just I mean the dude was
amazing
he wrote duel as well did you know that
yeah I have this so I have um a big
compilation of like all his short
stories chaotic Angel's saying he's
gonna have to see Omega Man again he
hasn't seen it in a long time yeah yeah
it's a good one yeah Celtic yeah Celtic
games to hello there I got my work
schedule changed so I'm off on Fridays
now hopefully I can join the Side Tracks
more often I hope so
yeah like last week we changed it to
Saturday but you know this week we
decided we were gonna do it on Friday
and even though we are going out tonight
but you know
said hi Jenny in time I'm okay with
child death I agree Critter death makes
me cry well honestly it's it's weird
because yeah but when I was a kid it was
similar yeah nowadays I'm just kind of
like you know if a horror movie if they
kill a cat or like a dog or something
like that I get mad that's gratuitous
killing me I'm like [__] that but it's
like if they kill a kid I'm like yeah
you go I know that's messed up it's not
real people it's okay it's a horror
movie but it's like I do like if they if
they're willing to to do that because I
know a lot of um movies will kind of
pull their punches it's like oh we don't
want to go there oh he's still alive
it's okay you know what I mean but yeah
leave the kitties and puppies alone but
to kill all the kids you want to Celtic
Angel the movies it's an old movie
very traditional in the way that it's
edited
it was kind of innovative for his time
in certain ways the subject matter that
they were that you know and
it's just a solid flick it's solid flick
especially for its time
and there's something about it it's kind
of eerie especially the first part of
the movie when he's by himself
kind of eerie and in a weird way kind of
comforting it's kind of got a nostalgic
feeling
it has a good good 1970s [__] score
there's there's like [__] yeah it's
kind of funky you got a funk in it
yeah it's classic and funk
um
it has
it's survival horror Adventure
it has some interracial romance in it
between a [__] military weapon
scientist who survived and he's kind of
monstrous that's [__] Neville
and basically a female black panther so
it's like the Opposites the two totally
opposite type people
thrown together and then there's a
family element where they're trying to
protect these little kids
and uh it's got a biker in there who was
who was a guy who uh
wasn't able to complete his university
biology or medicine
because uh education because the [__]
world ended
uh it's very La feelings 1970s La it's
that area where it's filmed and then the
hills around it
it's just a good flick you know
I was you know
grew up partially in La I left you know
in 1980
two or yeah 81 or 82 is when I left
so
I has childhood memories of the air of
that area it was it was a good place to
grow up I'm glad I'm not there now it's
too expensive to live there there's just
it doesn't over enough you know I'm in
the I'm in the new California Florida
which if you're from old California
you'd recognize Florida it's it's like
old Californian in some ways
um
but now it's a solid flip solid flick I
got it on Blu-ray
I would love to not Blu-ray uh DVD I'd
love it I'd love for this to get a
Blu-ray Deluxe release
like a steel book like a steel book yeah
why hasn't got a steel book yet I kind
of feel like of all the movies you're
[__] slacking man I mean a lot of
movies have steel books it needs a new
cover
you know what I mean yeah I'm not a big
fan of like the cover it has now it
needs to be a steel book there needs to
be some more extras
it needs to be uh remastered a bit but
you know even the DVD is pretty good
gender boss said I love 70s Cinema yeah
me too yeah I mean to be honest with you
if I had to pick if somebody put a gun
on my head
um probably the 70s is my favorite
decade for uh film but I mean I like
films from every era
going back to the silent era but the 70s
probably has the most the highest
concentration of my favorite movies
Louis says uh Jenny he wrote some
kick-ass TV movies in the 70s yeah
that's right Night Stalker yeah I
reviewed that over my other channels uh
Trilogy of Terror yeah that was the one
with Karen black sexy ass sexy ass Karen
Black in all three of them yeah uh and
he's the one that made Dracula and Vlad
the Impala the same person yeah that's
right
um so yeah he's like
he's kind of one of those guys it's like
one of those horror stalwarts man like I
kind of feel like
a lot of [__] that people know about
like modern horror tropes like
originated with him
Dave says Hey gotta go taking a quick
nap before going out see you both later
yeah we'll be out later on
have a good nap but you know I can't
take a nap at this if I took a nap now
I'd probably just sleep until the
morning
Jen says they took chances in the 70s
yeah I mean to be honest most of my
pretty much all my favorite horror
movies are from the 70s and 80s like
early 80s I kind of feel like
once
the mid 80s and 90s came along it's like
I still like a lot of movies from then
and I actually
um like a lot of movies from
recently like from the past 20 years or
something like that because I feel like
there was kind of a lull at least for me
like in the 90s and the 2000s but then
like in right around 2010 something like
that like [__] started getting good
again
but I kind of feel almost all of my
favorite horror movies are late 70s or
actually entire 70s and like early 80s I
kind of feel like like I'm until 82 or
83 because I was I love slasher movies
but I kind of feel like the 80s was very
slasher-centric I know there was a lot
of other stuff going on too but it's
like
and a lot of those got kind of samey and
I really like a lot of um you know I
really love if you've been around here a
long time you know that I really love um
Jello movies like Italian dollar movies
from the 1970s and I kind of feel like
they were still making gellos in the 80s
um but they were kind of getting a
little stale you know what I mean I kind
of feel like all the best ones came out
in the 70s and the like the late 60s
early 70s I kind of feel like all the
best ones came out okay what time do we
have to end the show yeah probably
nine-ish I mean I at least want to have
time to you're right yeah
okay you know just change clothes
yeah I know well you know been a good
show we're having fun we're having a
good time so since you mentioned I was
thinking this when you're talking about
the Omega Man that you saw it on cable
and it scared the crap out of you
broadcast television or whenever you saw
it local television California yeah so
you saw it when you were eight you said
about eight or nine eight and it scared
the [__] out of you yeah so I didn't
wasn't I didn't know what
post-apocalyptic
I wasn't quite sure what biological
warfare was I didn't know what a mutant
was
but it was I was putting it together I
was as I was watching it it was like oh
those people are normal they're sick
you know there's something wrong with
them and they take the glasses off and
they're like oh you know because they're
all albino looking and
yeah
so I'm gonna like ask what
other movies that you saw like scared
the [__] out of you as a kid and I'm
saying you might have seen it like giant
spider Invasion scared me which is
hilarious because that movie is terrible
terrible I saw it on Mystery Science
Theater piranha scared the [__] out of
me where that guy got his hand oh
piranha scared me too yeah when I was
little when did that come out 81 yeah so
I probably saw it when I was nine or ten
trying to think of uh
no piranha I think came out in the
[__] 70s late seven I thought it was
81 but I could be wrong about that they
said like maybe 78 maybe well anything I
told you before like remember when we
talked when we um reviewed the Oliver
Stone movie The Hand yeah I love that
one yeah um I told you anything that had
to do with like dismemberment yeah would
especially beheading but it didn't
necessarily have to be beheading it
could be any kind of dismemberment that
really like [__] me up it still kind
of does a little bit so it's like you
know the scene in The Omen like where
David Warner gets his head cut off by
the painted glass that scared the [__]
out of me yeah I was a kid holy crap but
it's like but it was like it fascinated
me too at the same time but it also like
horrified me and I kept thinking about
it
um gender boy said burnt offering scared
me saw that as a kid too yeah that
scared the crap out of me I first saw
that at a slumber party in the 80s
I was at my friend I think I was in
junior high maybe no maybe I was younger
than that I can't remember but I was at
this slumber party
my friend Tanya and she her dad was like
a heart surgeon or something and so they
lived in this huge [__] mansion and
it was me and her and like just a
handful of other girls like some of them
I didn't really know that well
and she had this house it was like an
old mansion and it had it was looked
like an old Haunted House legit like you
walked in there was like a [__] big
marble staircase with a [__]
chandelier I'm like holy [__] [__]
like my growing up in a trailer park ass
I was just like I'd never seen anything
like that except in the movies and so
like we go upstairs we get snacks and
stuff oh we're gonna watch movies we
rented like some horror movies and
there's like this [__] maze man you
go through back then there's all these
little rooms and [__] I'm like holy crap
like this house never ends and so we get
in this room and we're all piled up on
the couch and we start watching burnt
offerings and it's like that [__]
chauffeur yeah like pops up at the [__]
the first time that happened every
single girl that popped up and like ran
in all different directions I still
[__] remember that I mean we were
pretty small Jan Dubois said that that
it also scared her but I don't know what
she's taught him I should talk about
giant spider invasion
oh she said it was a core memory
it's so not as scary though I mean I
think well probably not to me because
the first time I saw it was on Mystery
Science Theater no where they were
making fun of it and I saw it in the
drive-in yeah yeah my dad took me to see
it in a drive-in
if I can uh
it was I think no it might have been
might have been the matinee no not
matinee might have been the 50th oh she
said I was talking about Omega Man a
Mega Man that's a non-giant spider
that's just well yeah because Invasion
[__] well it's what first got me about
giant spider invasion is that the spider
went in the blender and the girl drank
it
yeah see that's not bothered me even
Stephen King brought that up he's like
he's like look it's a terrible movie but
that scene yeah
um is like everybody can relate to that
because it's like oh gross you know what
I mean because that is pretty nasty but
the funniest thing to me about that
scene
is that when she made and I've seen this
movie probably like a hundred times
because like I said it's on Mystery
Science Theater and it's a really good
Mystery Science Theater episode so I've
watched it a bunch of times but the
scene where she where the Spider goes in
the blender
and then she drinks it is the funny
thing about it is that you see the
spider go in the blender and she's in
the blend and she's very very clearly
not looking at what she's putting in the
blender and it's very very obvious that
she's like la la not looking into
blender and it's like it's just very
very funny to me but then like she
drinks it in well that [__] was that
[__] was almost kind of like [__]
some vaudevillian right scene where
she's doing that and [__] her husband
or her husband her husband yes with her
little sister with the back brace yeah
is isn't he hitting on her little sister
yeah I'm pretty sure that's her younger
sister yeah it's pretty gross yeah like
it's just these really gross like
hillbilly it's it's Wisconsin I think
it's set in Wisconsin but
um the funny thing is the guy that plays
like the main farmer guy the guy with
the gross like back brace with stains on
it
uh and the and the long johns I think
that dude I don't think he directed it
but I think that later on he went on
became like a dialect coach because I
think he was on The Tonight Show and
[__] like that all the time which is
hilarious because it's a and the funny
thing is the giant spider is clearly a
Volkswagen Beetle with fur on it yeah
and legs shoving people up its ass yeah
that's my favorite part every it gets me
every single time like if you watch it
on Mystery Science Theater
well yeah like he eats like the spider
spoiler alert like the the spider eats
the the redneck dude and Tom Servo uh
the MST like the robot he says does it
matter that he ate him with his butt
like he very clearly just like stuff and
I'm just like oh my God it's just it's
so funny it's so funny
yeah that one scene really bothered me
in the blob where they the old man with
the what they found in the woods and
[__] it's eating up his arm
and then uh then it gets the doctor
didn't it get the doctor or the nurse
where he's trying to get out yeah yeah
that part that part scared me I mean the
original blob is I mean parts of it are
pretty scary now that in 1988 when I
would argue that the 1988 one is one of
the best remakes ever
I really like the 1988 remake of The
Blob another one that really made an
impression on me I probably probably was
around six seven eight around that time
was the old 1950s War of the Worlds yeah
I [__] loved it we reviewed that not
too long ago yeah that's a good movie
yeah and it was kind of It kind of
scared me
the concept oh yeah you can be you know
aliens could come and [__] your [__] up
you know what I mean that it was like
whoa
couldn't stop him
well yeah what are you gonna do yeah
Celtic Angel 73 said also Poltergeist I
shared a bedroom with my sister and
after I saw it I switched beds with her
because it was a tree outside the window
next to my bed yeah you're afraid the
tree was gonna reach in and like eat you
that didn't bother me they had other
ones culture guys kind of scared me they
had other ones that bothered me way into
my [__] teens
uh but I go back and look and watch them
and they were they they're not even
[__] bloody or scary and that was
[__] Halloween excuse me Friday the
13th one two and three
which are you pretty tamed everybody
today by today Sanders I was I guess
what 15 16.
14 15 16 around around that the original
Friday the 13th came out in 1980. and I
was seeing it later but you were saying
I've seen it later on cable they would
play them all at the same time and I
think I was around 15. no
younger
14 13 14. and that [__] would still
scare me because you know I was I was
spending summers in Mississippi
my friend's house
we were out in the middle of nowhere
and outside every one of those houses
was Woods so there was possibly a Jason
out there
I mean you know what I'm looking through
the window you know there could be a
Jason it could be a Jason out there
because I mean he's just he's probably
like not Supernatural but there could be
a serial killer for sure and um Friday
the 13th Part Two was the best one I
think it's still the best one
I agree I think number two is the best
one that's the one where uh
that's Jason's Lair and he's got the
Mama's head right plus that's the one
with Amy Steele and I kind of feel like
she um yeah she was in April Fool's Day
as well which is another one of my
favorite movies from the 80s but um
which is kind of like a quasi slasher
except kind of a it's kind of almost a
comedy but not quite but um and Terror
train I used to like that one yeah yeah
that's the one that's on New Year is
what Jamie did notice right that's a
Canadian film I think yeah and then I
don't think that one's even gory
now a lot of them weren't I kind of feel
like the weird thing about it is that
people are like ooh slasher movies but a
lot of them really weren't that gory
like is it the Italian ones were
um they showed all kind of [__] up
[__] like eye gougings and all that but
yeah the American ones were pretty tame
and I don't think because sometimes they
cut them too yeah you know like for
example
um you got like uh My Bloody Valentine
which was another Canadian slasher and
that came out in 1981 they remade it
later but it wasn't that good but the
original was actually much gorrier
because I've seen the original uh scenes
that they cut out but they cut a bunch
of [__] out I think people maybe in the
US you don't realize because we because
we got real smug over here about like
video nasties and like the UK and they
were cutting all these movies and stuff
they cut them in the U.S too but it's
like they don't make a big thing about
it so you don't really know unless you
kind of like look it up but you know
um
yeah Celtic Angel 73 said I agree the
1988 blob was one of the best remakes
I've ever seen yeah it kicked ass it was
it's really really good
um Jen Dubois said the rotting meat
scene in Poltergeist scared me I think
that was the scene that bothered me but
like the clown is [__] up I'm not like
scared of clowns or anything like that
but that was like a good scene with the
clown and the tree like eating the kid
and everything but I think yeah the the
scene that scared me the most was the
stake like going across the thing and
then going and then that guy going and
tearing his own face off which [__] that
was PG-13 yeah well they were hardcore
back then man the dude goes in the
bathroom and just starts tearing his
face off and I'm just like oh no oh no
trash Gordon was [__] PG-13 and there
was [__] drugs in it sex drugs and
sex slaves and you know I [__] loved
it man it was looking like erotic Star
Wars erotic Star Wars yeah [__] loves
that I love [__] the old flashcard
Camp guy said Phantasm I was older but I
had to walk home at like 2 A.M right
after I saw this the great thing about
fantastic fantastic once I got older is
that I love Phantasm like the first one
the second one's good too like I saw the
second one in the theater but the first
the whole that whole [__] franchise
every every episode is good every movie
is good
because the labor of love well because
they're I like them because they're like
surreal and they're like nightmare logic
and I like you know that can go stupid
like and that can go horribly wrong but
Phantasm he got it Don coscarella he got
it exactly right like that it's exactly
like what a nightmare is like what the
[__] was that what's up I thought I
heard something over there like pookie
was [__] around
no I thought like I heard her like
crashing around out there
um but yeah oh Trey said hey I got
distracted I'm going to see skinny puppy
now too in Atlanta got VIP ticket too
and it's a few days before her birthday
well [__] Trail says happy early
birthday she said I gotta go with Friday
the 13th Part three it's the first one
three was had a real clumsy edit I got
one two and three I have uh those three
movies
and three if you go back and look at it
the edit is [__] all over the place
and and it looks very low budget
but the thing about it is it has real
memorable
killing death scenes in it yeah
um
although the sleeping bag kill for
number seven is still my favorite I
don't remember that one
I think that's everything I don't I saw
the rest of them but I saw the rest of
his gags they started to get worse and
worse okay I think four was okay if I
remember I remember four maybe being
okay but my favorite is two
yeah two still my favorite yeah there's
something about two
the way it ended and I liked the one
with Corey Feldman which was either five
or six I think it was four wouldn't it
Corey film I don't remember like where
he was a little kid and he shaved his
head at the end
that one was good but um okay number
three was that the one that had the guy
that where they did the whole like
Outhouse gag where he got kind of like
trapped in the Outhouse or whatever I
don't remember
three was the one that uh didn't the
people start off and [__] it's been so
long didn't they start off they were
kind of like in a boy's home or people
for a home for the mentally Disturbed or
something
are you are you thinking about
neighboring Elm Street three no because
that one was set in a mental hospital no
it wasn't in a mental hospital it was it
was just it had some kids that come from
there I don't remember oh yeah maybe I
don't know I can't remember either I get
them all confused yeah Trey said I
always had a soft spot for Jason Takes
Manhattan
even though he didn't really Take
Manhattan that's like half the movie he
was just on the boat on the way to
Manhattan like he only gets there for
like five minutes because they didn't
have enough money to like shoot in
Manhattan so it's like it's super short
the sound of the ice in your drinks
makes me thirsty yeah
yeah and Trey said it's where he found
the hockey mask that's right yeah uh Tom
is talking about Friday 13th five yeah
that's what I thought okay yeah yeah
because in the in the first one I've
seen almost all of them in the first one
Jason wasn't the killer the mom was
um you know Betsy baller I just
remembered like him and then the second
one he had a bag over his head yeah I
just remember liking Phantom Kelly
remember liking one two three and maybe
I think four were the best ones I think
if I remember I mean two like I said two
still my favorite I well I kind of feel
like maybe it's because I saw that one
the most but I really like
I really like Amy stealing it I've
always really liked her as an actress so
it's like she you know she's very
charismatic so I think she carries and I
really like the end where she's like
pretending to be Jason's mom like I
always really liked that yeah and where
she finds the hat and everything yeah
really it should have ended right there
but who am I to say that well I mean
they continued to make money on that
[__] over and over that's what I'm
saying if like the [__] still makes
money they're gonna make they're gonna
keep making this it should have ended it
too I mean artistic it's anything
doesn't mean anything they're just like
well the last one made 40 bajillion
dollars so we're gonna make another one
yeah even if it makes less than that
Jason doesn't have a [__] hockey mask
on his head he had a bag on his head
with a single thing yeah
like he didn't even have the hockey mask
yeah [__] the hockey man it's just a bag
with a [__] hole like a potato sack
on his head it looked cool as [__] when
I was kidding like ah what the [__]
although you think it's like yeah why
did he even have one why did he cut out
another hole or was it they can't
because they just they would just
telegram to me they only had one eye
that he couldn't see out of the other
one maybe that's why but still you
wouldn't be able to see even if you had
one eye you would be able to see a
little hole
yeah
I mean it's just yeah why would you even
wear a bag over your head no no if you
were if you were if you were a real bad
[__] let everybody see you yeah
it's like yeah yeah eventually take a
picture yeah yeah
I'm trying to think of like stuff that
scared me when I was a kid and this is
gonna be hilarious if you've actually
seen it recently one movie that scared
the crap out of me when I was a kid and
I saw it when I don't remember how old I
was I was probably too young to see it
but um
do you guys remember children shouldn't
play with dead things I think it came
out in the early 70s I want to say
and I saw it on cable
like late one night because I was always
because I loved creepy [__] like from
birth pretty much I don't remember
I never I don't remember a time that I
never liked creepy [__]
um even though it did scare me when I
was a kid but that was it was like an
adrenaline rush so whenever something
creepy was on I'd be like well I'm
watching this [__] even if I have
nightmares for a week or whatever so
um that movie
I watched that and it scared the crap
out of me for I don't know why and like
I I didn't watch it again for a really
long time because like man that scared
the [__] out of me as a kid I wonder
what it was about it and then like I
watched it again recently I'm like what
the [__] was I even scared I don't even
know what I was scared of it's not scary
at all but
I mean it's a good movie it's fun movie
It's let's it looked like it costs about
two dollars to make but it's still like
pretty entertaining
but I don't know what scared me so much
about it and I think also the first time
that I saw
um The Shining
which that came out in 1980 so I was
eight when it came out I don't think I
saw in the theater but I think I saw it
as soon as it came on cable and that the
scene in the bathroom like with the
rotting lady in the top that oh that
[__] me up that [__] me up real bad
and I did not like that at all
um
Trey said I was basically a goth at
Birth too yeah I mean honestly as soon
as I could read
you know because I learned to read
really pretty pretty young and as soon
as I learned to read all I wanted to do
was like read ghost stories
even before I knew what goth was or even
before any of that
it was weird because
I and I got into like The Adams Family
and all that kind of stuff and I'm like
wow I was like wow look at Morticia and
all this like the original Adams Family
like the black and white one like when I
was a kid I saw it on reruns and I was
like that's woo that's what I want to
look like so that and like stories about
witches and stuff because I was really
into witches when I was a kid too
and then like when I got older like when
it was like the late 70s early 80s and I
discovered that there was this whole
subculture of like people that were into
like creepy [__] too I was like I
thought I was the only person so it's
like I'm always like The Accidental goth
because it's kind of like I got it I was
into creepy [__] and then I realized oh
there's all these other people also
under creepy [__] I thought I was the
only person you know what I mean
um nothing used to scare me when I was a
kid is every [__] episode of the
[__] um Night Gallery
I
love Night Gallery
I made well I did um
on my scare Salon Channel I did um I
talked about the pilot yeah of Night
Gallery and I've been wanting to do the
series like I said I'm doing Boris
Karloff Thrillers you and I want to
finish that but I do want to do Night
Gallery because I've seen the Night
Gallery Series like a million times and
it's so good Ross early yeah
[__] was he was this [__] I
honestly I know this might be a
controversial statement but I actually
like Night Gallery A bit better I love
the Twilight Zone don't get me wrong but
I kind of love net Gallery more than
Twilight Zone because Night Gallery was
more I kind of feel like Night Gallery
is more horror focused it was more like
easy Comics whereas Twilight Zone was
kind of like a lot of also morality
Tales but some of them were
more like sci-fi you know what I mean
which is fine but I kind of like more
pure horror kind of stuff and I kind of
feel like Night Gallery more went in
that direction and I really liked the
premise of Night Gallery had some
disturbing ass episodes man it did yeah
some of them were [__] remember they had
what was his name Carradine [__]
uh [__] David Carradine's dad was in
it he's this old bug John Kerry news I
want you to go that tree and pick out 10
Paces by that win ticket you will find a
big surprise man that's it and those
kids are out there digging and they find
a big old [__] coffin looking thing
the box and they open it up and [__]
carrotine jumps it goes surprise
see I really gotta do now
I watched the whole thing I've watched
the whole series like several times
through like I think the last time was
probably
five or six years ago and then the best
the best Twilight Zone the one that
scared the [__] out of me when I was a
kid was the old lady in the [__]
sleeping in her bed at night and the
[__] electrical storms going outside
and [__] somebody keeps calling her
and [__] oh like oh yeah he's calling
this old lady at night or old-fashioned
phone she goes she goes hello and it's
just a person person's voice going hello
hello just hello I hear you hello
and the [__] went on and on and off
finally she's gonna I need you to trade
she's called the Operator Operator
please trace this call who is it that's
calling me [__] and then the next day
that we traced the call there's a down
line over in this area and a [__] the
line fell from the storm and the [__]
the telephone line was wrapped around
her husband's grave and she's calling
her he was calling her back because
there was something and that's all he
could say hello no I went on into some
of the [__] she kept [__] with him
when he was alive he was calling back
you didn't you know you were [__] me
over [__] you know that kind of [__] I
don't remember exactly what it was you
never listened to me she dominated him
or something but he was alive she's like
you know I can just not pick up the
phone
you're dead [__] ass calling me
shut up
anything like that what for some reason
I'm always really creeped out still am
actually by weird
um like voice kind of things like okay
for example
you know in the changeling
uh you know the scene from 1980 with
George he's got it's a great [__]
movie If I haven't seen it but one of my
favorite haunted houses of all time
um you know the the Seance there is no
Ghost in This House well you know this
stay on scene where like they where they
do the recording and they have the
medium and she's talking in that really
flat affect yeah and that that freaks me
out I don't know why it's like people's
voices like going like that and I've
talked about this I've talked about this
like on my blog I think I've talked
about other places too but like any
scene where
you know like where where Danny starts
uh in The Shining where he like is doing
the Red Rum thing and it's like he just
keeps saying red Rob and then like his
voice goes up in Pitch it's like that
always kind of like freaks me out and
there's a scene too in the original
Nightmare on Elm Street
where uh if you remember from 1984 where
Nancy is sitting in her English class
and she falls asleep but we don't know
that like and she doesn't realize it and
the guy there's like a kid in the front
of the room and he's reading from like a
Shakespeare play I can't remember which
one it is and he's reading from it and
he's like reading normal but then like
once she falls asleep he just starts
going
like he starts like Whispering like that
and then like she looks and like sees
Tina in the body bag like in the hall
and it's like that [__] scene freaks
me out and I think it's mostly because
of the voice thing like I don't know why
but like people's voice so anytime like
anybody talks in that weird flat affect
or like they their voice changes
suddenly or something like that it like
wears me out and I don't really know why
you guys said Night Gallery is great
yeah I love Night Gallery
um and they were talking about the
Twilight Zone was ahead of its time the
80s Twilight Zone says Celtic Angel was
pretty good too there were a lot of very
creepy episodes yeah I keep wanting to
revisit the 80s Twilight Zone I remember
seeing it back then but I didn't like I
like Twilight Zone The Movie from back
then from 83 or whenever that came out
um there was also an eight a 90s series
I think it's called Tales from the Dark
Side yeah yeah I didn't never got to see
him well they did a movie yeah they did
an anthology movie which is excellent
yeah it had Christian Slater in it
Debbie Harry was in it
um you know all the stories in that were
good but
um yeah I think they did a series as
well well there was kind of like because
I guess you had Tales from the Crypt
like um HBO did tells from the Crypt and
that was like hugely successful so there
was a lot of like horror Anthology [__]
going on they even did like a Friday the
13th series which didn't have [__] all
to do with the movies and I think they
did a um
they did a Freddy went here and they did
Freddy's nightmares I don't remember if
that one had anything to do you know I
never really liked Nightmare on Elm
Street the first one is amazing actually
the first one and the third one are
amazing oh and the new nightmare I just
thought they were okay it's good they're
like The Meta one that one's good I only
saw him on you know uh VHS we were
renting them and they were good you know
fun enough to watch with a date or
something or
hanging out with your [__] high
school buddies watching the [__] but
they never really stuck with me
and that was the same thing with uh
Hellraiser if there was something always
mediocre about Hellraiser which is weird
because those are like way more
imaginative than the Friday the 13th
movie and for some reason they just came
across as like there were parts of them
I thought were really good but the rest
of it was just kind of mediocre
I just it's like there wasn't enough
special effects there wasn't enough of
what I liked in them well the thing
should have just been Center bites
fighting or some [__] like that you know
yeah you say that about every movie it
should have just been fill in the blank
fighting [__] fight instead of all that
[__] story and characters yeah we
just want to see stuff fighting yeah I
didn't really the story parts of it
didn't really impress me that much but
the special effects did in the time now
I I will go on I like the the nightmare
in Elm Street franchise but I will go on
record as saying like the first one is
creepy as hell and I think that they
should have stuck with that because
Freddy was actually scary in the first
one and then after that they tried that
he just got more more clownish like as
time went on and it's just kind of like
so it got to a point where they were
like well we're just now he's like a
character so now we're trying to make
him like funny and like a comedian and
then we're just like trying to see how
absurd we can make just for the special
effects team to like have fun so we're
just gonna make like you know it's like
hey let's shrink this girl down to the
size of a road and put her in a roach
motel and squish her you know what I
mean it's like that kind of which is
funny but it's like it's not scary
though I kind of feel like the first
Nightmare on Elm Street was actually
scary none of the other ones were scary
although the third one was a good was
good though we loved anything with any
any of that [__] uh reanimator things
that we saw anytime or anything it was
like reanimator uh anything with Jeffrey
Combs do we like that we love Jeffrey
Combs he's badass yeah and then Dagon I
have that I have a [__] Blu-ray
steelbook special edition Dagon release
she got me that was for my birthday I
think I think so yeah man that [__]
that's so underrated
um that's one of the better like
Lovecraft adaptations yeah I think even
though it's not an adaptation of Dagon
It's actually an adaptation they
actually they actually wanted to get
um uh uh what's his name what's his name
[__] [__] I just did his name
Jefferson they wanted to get Jeffrey
combs in that but he was a little too
old to be the lead character because it
was supposed so you're supposed to be
clouds dude yeah but uh well he could
have been a returning college student
yeah I want to change the story or a
professor or something I mean they could
have I mean it would have been a really
easy like fix you know yeah because it
did that dude there was nothing in the
story that said that dude had to be a
college student yeah it's all we haven't
had a guest on the show in a long time
but have you ever had a guest on it
would be Cubs I'd love to [__] get
Jeffrey Carlson let's just talk about
strand we'll get him drunk and like talk
about it have you ever seen Combs on a
show he drinks on the show okay like we
do yeah he has a lot of fun on it so a
man after her excuse me one city goes up
and takes a leak
sorry I had to go get my flask yeah and
I'm just like there's a real good
interview with him with some [__]
hardcore horror fans and some of them
just knew everything that he was in and
one dude bought the resonator he owns
the the real resonator from the movie
and [__] Combs mind was [__] blown
he's like you have the resonator yes I
bought the resonator you have the
resonator because yeah yeah I have it
I would like to see the resonator one
time well come on over here we'll have a
barbecue dude [__] bought the
resonator for [__] thousands of
dollars off of some auction
and his house was nothing but just like
a shrine to horror movies and a lot of
it was Jeffrey Combs see if I had the
money I would totally yeah I'd love to
have something like that I would totally
do that it was like a horror Museum
uh I don't remember the name of the
channel but if you look up Jeffrey Combs
interviews it's one of the best big best
interviews he's got with the most hits
on it and it's a good show man he's a
real good guest
he seems super fun he's real classy he
seems like even when he's drunk he's
classy he seems like somebody I can
handle yeah but like I said I really
like
I don't know I kind of and I think I've
said this before because I'm such a
horror nerd and I think maybe a lot of
horror nerds like kind of feel the same
way it's like you always want these
people that you admire like in horror
movies
to be as into them as you are so it's
always kind of like disappointing when
you find out it's like I don't really
like horror movies I just did it for the
paycheck or something you're like ah you
kind of suck but like when you have
somebody like that that is so
appreciative and they will go on all the
horror things and they'll go to all the
conventions and they'll like hang out
with everybody and they seem to be as
into it as you are that's like way
cooler comes his way into that [__]
that's what I see that's like way cool
he's also big into Star Trek because he
did so much work on Star Trek Enterprise
and Deep Space Nine he probably did some
[__] on Voyager he was on a lot of star
trees absolutely that's awesome and he
was saying that he fantasized about
actually having a spin-off movie
of Commander sharan as Charan was one of
the best [__] characters in in in
Enterprise that's right take all my
money yeah I would go see that oh yeah
he was the if you guys know if you don't
know what I'm talking about
shran was an endorian Captain all right
from some kind of royal guard that the
indoors and the endorian guys are the
blue guys with the white hair and the
antennas suction cups and he was kind of
like
the the andorian Captain Kirk he's he's
real cool in in the series and he's a
regular on Enterprise he shows up and
does [__] and helps out Archer and and
he's just a good dude a real strong
Battlefield Commander
but he's serving a corrupt government he
knows it's corrupt it doesn't he doesn't
he obeys it but he doesn't believe in
what he's doing it's just he's a very
good character you know he doesn't think
that he doesn't think that the
government he's serving is Honorable and
it isn't but he you know so he does what
he's ordered to do but mitigates it by
cheating
you know what I mean to help
to help his friends which was Archer at
the time [__] it's good it's a good
story good story that'd make a great
movie
yeah I would watch that they they
probably should do it yeah because it'd
be real complicated yeah basically an
alien captain
whose honorable tough ass [__]
is kind of kind of reminds me of George
C Scott out of Patton he's kind of like
that
um
and he's trying to get the mission done
but his commanding officers and his
superiors are [__] scumbags basically
tell them to [__] people over when he
really shouldn't be [__] people over
but he has to obey but he has to figure
out how to [__] mitigate that how to
make it and run around
and uh I liked it because the andorian
guys were all small they were all of
like you know five five six five four
like that and the women were all six
feet tall basically
edit his commanding officer was a female
and she made a move on him and he had no
choice he either had to marry her or
[__] imprison her
so he decided he'd marry her [__]
this because he didn't really did
explain what that was about but he just
that's what he told what's his name
Celtic Angel 73 said there's a 2016
movie called Attack of the Killer Donuts
you guys should check it out it's
hilarious
okay I will definitely watch that we're
gonna have to wrap this up though Jen
it's time for us to start getting yeah I
gotta start getting ready to go yep but
uh but yeah this has been I always like
a little show I always like when we talk
about well I always like when we talk
about music or horror movies yeah you
know what I mean so I don't know if the
audience enjoys it if you enjoy the show
please well I mean they're kind of like
they're in there they're all charging in
so you know everybody's got their you
know they wouldn't be here you know it's
it's [__] sci-fi horror fandom what
we're talking about sure yeah like I
said we all grew up on the same you give
me talking about horror movies I'll talk
all night long yeah so that's probably
not that's probably not good because we
probably should go yeah but uh but yeah
so hopefully you guys have a good day
tomorrow
uh we'll probably be back on
Sunday we'll probably do a matinee show
I mean we might talk about the Top Gun
movie if we finish watching it
um because we watched it like halfway or
we might watch something else I don't
really know how it would soon do you
want to do you want to review the the
Maverick movie or we can review Top Gun
or we can or we can think of something
else we'll worry about it at the time
we'll worry about it but maybe one or
the other we'll see how it goes so uh
thank you everybody for dropping by this
evening thank you for super chats and
we'll see you guys again on
Sunday good night